I loved my fiance but after this things
changed forever two years earlier our
life together had seemed so promising I
knew he was the one as soon as I met him
I'd broken up with my ex-boyfriend a few
months previously and I was ready to
meet someone new so I signed up on the
dating app bumble and that was how I
found Joe Jelly's a Dutch software
engineer working for Google in London he
was kind quirky and funny I was a school
physics teacher so we were both quite
nerdy science types and I loved how
active he was always going around
running or climbing in his spare time we
were both so sure the relationship was
right and we told each other during our
second date this is it this is you doll
this is it got off we had got together
during the pandemic in summer 2020 meet
h30 him 34 and when the second lockdown
was announced I asked him to move in
although so early in relationship it
didn't feel too soon living together in
high Barrett North London grew even
closer quicker than we might have done
otherwise both of us are working from
home isolated from others and spending
quality time together I always think
that a great way of telling if you have
a good relationship is if you feel like
you're a better person when you're with
your partner I felt that with jelly he
challenged me to be kinder more aware of
what is going on in this world more
Curious I was so happy felt so lucky to
admit this amazing man don't worry I'm
not just reading fan fiction this is
this is good
we didn't know at this point the cruel
twist that laid wait for us that
throughout our relationship something
was happening to jelly
it wasn't until the day after Joey's
37th birthday that symptoms started to
appear he woke up feeling dizzy and
nauseous at first we just assumed it was
a hangover from our celebration but the
sisters symptoms never went away instead
they grew worse then about a month he
was vomiting all the time and he would
plan a few trips abroad but we had to
cancel it because Joey just wasn't
feeling too Welly
initially doctors told him it was
Vertigo and told him he would get better
but he just had to wait but we continued
to would he continue to feel sick so he
could work we plan to get engaged and I
knew Charlie was going to propose in the
summer when we were on holiday but we
had to cancel the holiday so I thought
I'm going to go proposave instead this
isn't going to get in the way of our
future a few weeks after engagement we
received that the really devastating
news that more detailed the scans had
shown generally had a brain tumor and it
wasn't benign it was a rare type of
cancer of the central nervous system
called medulla blastoma more often
seeing children than adults jelly was
told that the chance of him getting
getting it had been one in four million
his chances of surviving five years was
65 percent both of us broke down in
tears but while I went to pieces and
remained a Miss for a long time
afterwards jelly was remarkably strong
and calm he never once said why I'm here
it's not fair his attitude was these are
the cards I've been dealt and I just
have to get on with it that's
anyways carry on but I knew that I could
not stay with them watching helplessly
as he got sicker and sicker over the
preceding three months had been bad
enough but the uncertainty of the
diagnosis brought was too too much for
me spent many sleepless nights
researching trying to find a miracle
cure or starting with a good outcome but
I could find was uncertainty and Bleak
statistics statistics Not only was there
a significant chance of the cancer
returning the future but there was a
possibility of long-term and sometimes
delayed side effects from the
radiotherapy and chemotherapy treatment
on the spring I felt like the man I
loved was slipping away from me and I've
been so close to having everything I
wanted all of a sudden it had been
snatched away I couldn't eat her sleep I
was suffering from panic attacks I told
my mother and his I can't do this I
can't stay with him they warned me not
to tell them the decision until at least
after the surgery so I went to see my
mother's in late September jelly went to
the hospital for 17 hours to remove the
term tour the operation was successful
but he lived with quite severe brain
damage and had to get used to living
with disabilities he had double vision
Paralysis on his right side he also had
motor skill issues and had to learn how
to write and walk again despite all this
he had coped amazingly well me less so
we had a brief conversation about our
future before surgery and admitted I was
struggling but there's a chance it can
be cure he protested I ended our
relationship two weeks later he was
still recovering in the hospital and I
sat and I faced him on the chair and
told them I couldn't stay with him I
can't see a way I could be happy with
you anymore I said I I said devastated I
knew I would be no good for him because
I couldn't even function myself due to
the uncertainty of it all he needed
strength and optimism I could not
provide that we shift tears and then for
the future we didn't have I'm still
trying to come to terms with my decision
at the time I felt like the worst person
in the world and I know if I heard the
story about someone else I would think
they were selfish this is partly why I
wanted to write this article because
it's very easy for society to make
judgments but in situations like this
where there aren't clear cut right and
Wrongs sometimes we need to remember we
can't judge someone wearing under shoes
jelly understood as did my friends he
and I remain close friends that was it
did he die no he still left okay if I
was in the position of jelly I would
send the girl away true that's me that's
because that's me
actually
that's a cause that and that's the way I
am there's some people that you are the
way you are and that's fine me I
couldn't I don't want to see her like
that and staying there and being all
miserable and [__] yo bro
it was nice Love Is Love You Gotta yo
dashika I would let her go so and now I
would never want to be an increase and
you could be like oh this is the same
this is this and that whatever I relied
on my I rely on my family and stuff like
that I know I think that my girl
wouldn't do it
but I will still be like hey yo this is
Doom right now okay and the way I'm
thinking most of the people really think
that sometimes I am negative where I
believe that I am realistic right uh in
that case I'm like yo go do go go out do
your thing live your life please I don't
want to see that as a matter of fact
it's on a different scale okay it's like
one of my girl go out my girl doesn't
want to go out she doesn't really like
people like that so if we go someplace
right or we go to a comedy thing or a
Gala or something like that she's gonna
be next to me and then she gonna be
miserable because she doesn't like it to
be here now I'm gonna be miserable cause
I'm always worried about her yeah and
I'm gonna be it happens sometimes like
yo you're not having fun I'm about to
you know I'm I'm about to have some fun
go home you're not you're cool I'm cool
I can handle myself just because now
you're not having fun you're not
comfortable I don't like you seeing I
don't like to see you like that so go
home and do your thing I would hate to
be the reason that my loved one is
constantly suffering exactly so if you
blow it up in a different different
scale I I'm in the predicament that he
is I'm like yo you could go out and just
do your thing because I don't want to be
the reason I see you when you're
struggling and you're ah no I don't want
to be I don't want to be that person
again this is all time dependent to me
three years in engaged and not married
like I ain't even that mad okay 10 years
in married with kids we have in a
different discussion yeah definitely 20
years in no kill we having a different
discussion yeah we're having a
discussion right for them I know
everybody wants to be hyper judgmental
but like I get it like
that's death that's a whole Cloud
looming over the whole thing the whole
time yeah she's what in her early 30s
her chance to have kids
y'all be talking about that all the time
biological clock all these things like
that that's a hard one to Summit yeah
also living with somebody with a
disability if that's not what it was at
the beginning and like in the first two
three years you find that that person is
no longer gonna be able to walk or use
their body much like that's another
thing too
all right listen y'all can see whatever
you want and I get with the girl in the
first two years and then I found out for
whatever reason she can't have sex ever
again move past the six if I find out
she can't have kids I'll find out she no
longer gonna have her legs her arms a
few years from now
but
I understand that
she left I understand that she left with
the circumstances and everything and
stuff it's kind of it can be like take a
toll on you okay was it selfish
absolutely yes it was I don't think that
being selfish is inherently a bad thing
it's a thing right and depending on
whatever how you do it it becomes a good
or bad thing but yes you were thinking
about yourself and your well-being and
how you would and I understand that and
your feelings were gone you did the
selfish thing you said you know let me
let me let me duck out of here because
I'm not gonna be happy if you figure
that you were not going to be happy and
you didn't do your man the same way
that's for you I understand that
but if miraculously he becomes better
and he finds another girl and he's about
happiness then then you get
I want to go back no I can't me on this
on the side of jelly if I saw that no
you can't go back I can't rely on you
you're not
you was not there for me so I could uh
with friends and everything and stuff
but no you can't get some of this back
but what do you say to somebody who said
she was about to be married to this guy
through sickness and then health
what do you say to those people yeah you
shouldn't get married to him she got
engaged she was about to she didn't get
married to him so she didn't sign the
valve do you think that would have
changed something nope okay and to those
people I say it is what it is you I
think those people that say through
sickness in it I think you're right but
some people like again we said that
before right we already had this
conversation with talk show marriage to
some people is not really what what the
vows and everything and stuff it's
really about the wow the pizzazz the
gold the ring the ceremony they're
showing off the people the boats thing
you understand what I'm saying that's
what they want that's the wedding date
they want the wedding day they don't
want a marriage they want a day they
want that day where everything is all
about them and they want to live that
maybe that's that as well they don't
think about the vows [__] don't
think about the vows even when most
people I could say this that most people
when they see them vows they don't
really understand the vows when they
sign the paper it's not really about the
vowels in the paper most people I could
say that I think a lot of that yeah I
see I think a lot of people who are
doing all this talking
they got their own breaking points they
got their own things that if their
partner wasn't doing or wasn't able to
do they would cut absolutely I know a
lot of these men be like see women are
not alone if you found out your girl
wasn't down to bang you no more or if
you're a girl let's say lost the ability
to have kids and y'all never had kids I
think a lot of you guys would have said
everybody got a Breaking Point
through this and that yeah okay if you
really if you like anything in the Bible
basically yeah like anything in the
Bible or anything in any holy books
I'm religious yeah to what extent
I believe in those things to what extent
okay and and then again I'm not saying
it's good or bad I don't care that's
your business but who you yeah who you
connect with that's on you that's not on
me I don't care yeah I mean listen and
it's I think people sent me this article
because they would be like yo look at
this [__] nah Lizzy if I was dating
some girl and I really really wanted to
be with her and I found out she probably
only got three years to live I'm not
gonna lie
I don't think I could handle that it's
not a lot and there's not a lot of
people that could yeah it's different
when you're 20 years they married like
if I was with the same person for a day
okay we talking something different if
we like in the first two three years and
I find out you dying in four five I
might be like I don't think I can handle
that oh I I would if some people like I
don't give a [__] I'll say this at the
end of this you said listen you haven't
been in that person's shoes you can't
judge I think you can judge just be
honest ask yourself some tough questions
what is your Breaking Point what's the
point where you say no what's your
breaking point and be honest think about
what the worst things that can happen
within the Dynamics of a relationship or
marriage that are three years in at what
point you saying I ain't going to
continue with this just ask yourself the
question if your person gets a needle
and they have AIDS you're gonna stay
with them they get in a car accident
lose both their legs their arms they
scarred up you're gonna stay with them
some of you are going to say yes and
maybe that's true for you I just want
everyone to be honest about what they
can or can't that's all I'm saying yeah
a lot of you are fronting on the
internet talking about I would stay no
matter what I say no matter what a lot
of the people who say stuff like that
have never been those kind of scenarios
or those kinds of dating Dynamics I
don't know why I know because people who
are in those kind of situations with
disability will tell you it's often a
problem with the people I think there's
not enough people who are honest about
the fact that they would have an issue
with that and too many people virtue
signaling online
um
go as disabled people how easy it is to
date somebody lying and I guarantee you
it's probably the people in the comment
section that's all I'm assume
that's all I'm gonna say anything else
you want to say no sir all right we want
to hear from you what do you guys think
let us know in the comments